I feel like this shirts completely out
of season this is a summer shirt it is
it's not summer but it is laundry day I
could say that so all my peeps down in
Australia enjoying the Sun right now
this shirts for you
[Music]
Green books or green book stars Viggo
Mortensen and rehearsal Olly in
characters that are not like those
characters which really shows the range
in their acting ability this is based on
the true story Viggo Mortensen plays a
tough guy unrecognizable as Viggo
Mortensen but saying Viggo Mortensen
isn't tough I'm just saying he plays
that tough-guy tough talking Italian
also self-proclaimed master bullshitter
just a different role different than
Aragorn anyway or the devil in prophecy
or the dude in Hidalgo and rehearsal
Halle plays doc he's an artist he plays
the piano he's part of a trio he's a
very cultured sophisticated gentleman
they play classical music so Doc's gonna
do a music tour in the South in America
in 1961 and he needs a bit of a tough
guy to be his driver bodyguard and
personal assistant enter Tony that's
Viggo Mortensen so these two are in a
road trip together and not only were
Viggo Mortensen and myrrh Herschel Ollie
great they were great together they just
have great chemistry I love the fact
that these two are just thrown into this
situation this tough guy Tony whose
horizons have not been broadened by
culture and sophistication and this very
cultured gentleman type and they're
nothing alike they wouldn't elect to
hang out together at a fete and the job
of brought them together it's just a
music it's not amusing in that planes
trains and automobiles kind of way this
isn't a comedy by any stretch of the
imagination but that scenario that
situation is just amusing to see at
first and you get attached to the
characters and you just you see them
grow but I really like that this movie
did usually the scenario is the rigid
standoffish one is going to learn how to
be a little more tolerant my way of
hanging out with the lovable loudmouth
but that just shows growth from one of
the two people this movie shows that
both people will grow and if growth
isn't the right word what I mean to say
is both will gain perspective which I
suppose by definition is growth because
we're all essentially computers for hard
drives and we annex information from our
interactions with people the places we
go the scenarios and situations that we
take part in you can't throw two people
together and have only one of them learn
from the situation granted if doc didn't
grow in this situation he'd be better
off than Tony like Tony probably
required more growth doc would be fine
this doesn't change the fact that doc
still needed to grow in his own right so
I'm glad they showed that both people
can learn something from each other and
really this is just a peer very
enjoyable character movie I mean
Tony's his bodyguard yeah it's not like
he throws down every other stop that
they make he's more of a deterrent than
anything he was a couple of racist
[ __ ] they do run into them but the
scenarios you're interested in aren't
the people out there they're the people
in the car anything is I almost don't
know why it's called green book like
green bucks where there's little
pamphlets that was like all right here's
where black people can go and stay if
you're touring in the south so it's
relevant they do use it but calling it
green books is kind of a weird call feel
like I'm running into that Siskel and
Ebert scenario for that movie it could
happen to you I remember watching the
review back in the nineties and they
were like why is it cult it could happen
to you I mean granted it could happen to
you it's just not the best title for the
scenario there's kind of what I'm
running into I feel like there's gonna
be another movie that really dives into
the Green Book like what the Green Book
was who made it like a movie about a
green book and I can't call it green
book now because this is called green
book movie that uses green book but it
really should be called two guys driving
but guys in the end I really dug green
book my Hershel alley was fantastic
Viggo Mortensen was great you really see
the contrast like the dynamic of the
range of their acting ability and they
worked well together they had good
chemistry together it was just a very
enjoyable personal story about
friendship growth and growth of
friendship a growth of character a
growth of perspective it is a very human
movie at a really good time with it I'll
say Green books worth watching and
worthwhile on blu-ray right so Green
Room have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below call it Green Room or Green books
just now I don't know [ __ ] alright we'll
do another one all right so green book
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
[Music]